Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Florencia Fragapane
Ho ascoltato, ho guardato
centinaia di TED Talk nella mia vita;
ma non avrei mai pensato di tenerne uno.
Non sono proprio
dove avevo programmato di essere.
Alzi la mano chi di voi è nella situazione
personale, familiare, o fisica -
o professionale, lavorativa ed economica -
che aveva pianificato anni fa?
Mi chiedo quindi se chi siamo, dove siamo,
sia il risultato di una pianificazione,
di un metodo,
di un controllo attento
delle nostre azioni
e delle relative conseguenze;
oppure sia il risultato
di una serie di reazioni
ad avvenimenti casuali
che ci sono successi.
Siamo padroni del nostro destino?
È un mantra che ci siamo sentiti ripetere
tante volte, in diversi contesti.
Avere la convinzione che la nostra vita
non sia lasciata al caso,
ma siamo noi ad averne le redini,
indubbiamente ci rassicura.
Siamo noi i padroni del nostro futuro.
Siamo noi che decidiamo il nostro futuro
con la nostra volontà,
con la nostra tenacia,
con la nostra bravura.
Ma è davvero così?
Perché a me invece, a volte,
sembra di vivere una vita
come se fosse una corsa
in equilibrio su una fune.
Avete presente quei giochini,
gli endless run, che vanno
tanto di moda adesso
dove l'imprevisto
è sempre dietro l'angolo?
Un imprevisto lavorativo,
un imprevisto di salute,
o un imprevisto logistico.
Anche piccolo, anche positivo.
Non sto parlando necessariamente
di grandi tragedie.
Arriva l'imprevisto, e saltano i piani.
Vengono disattese le mie aspettative.
E quindi la prima domanda
che mi faccio, il primo dubbio,
è sempre: ho sbagliato qualcosa.
Potevo prevederlo.
E poi l'ansia da ripianificazione.
Adesso cosa faccio?
La necessità di riprendere
subito il controllo.
Ora,
questa pianificazione,
imprevisti, ripianificazione
é un lavoro psicologico immenso,
che ci occupa tutti i giorni.
A me genera stress.
A me personalmente mi si forma
un piccolo mattone qua, sul petto,
che mi impedisce
di finire bene il respiro.
Mi sento un po’ chiuso in gabbia.
E allora mi vengono di nuovo,
mi metto di nuovo in discussione.
Possibile che non riesco
a godermi quella quotidianità
che ho, faticosamente,
costruito in tanti anni?
Possibile che non riesca a vivere
la mia giornata con maggiore leggerezza?
E quindi inizio a cercarmi delle evasioni,
un po’ di spazio solo per me.
Quelle due ore che ti prendi
solo per te nella giornata;
inizi a sognare ad occhi aperti.
Le leggende metropolitane:
l'amico che ha preso la famiglia
e ha aperto il chiringuito
sulla spiaggia del paese tropicale
dove costa tutto pochissimo,
c'è sempre il sole,
i bimbi giocano scalzi nella sabbia.
Andiamo.
Ma se pianificare mi genera questo stress,
e lo stress mi genera infelicità,
e voglia di evadere,
è sbagliato pianificare?
È sbagliato pensare
alle conseguenze delle nostre azioni?
È sbagliato pensare a chi vogliamo essere,
nei diversi ruoli della nostra vita?
Uomini, donne, genitori,
figli, amici, colleghi.
È sbagliato impegnarsi
per realizzare i nostri sogni?
Evidentemente non è così.
È una semplificazione che non vale:
non vale perché il mondo di oggi
è disordinato, è frammentato
e guidato da una tecnologia
che a volte sembra superare
i nostri limiti di pensiero e di azione.
Una tecnologia affascinante,
a volte inquietante:
la usiamo per relazionarci,
la usiamo per osservare, per osservarci,
la usiamo per scegliere continuamente.
E scegliamo cosa ascoltare, cosa leggere,
cosa guardare, come viaggiare.
Scegliamo continuamente,
e nello scegliere abbiamo la sensazione
di avere il controllo.
Poi ci guardiamo intorno
e vediamo sì un mondo controllato;
ma condito da insicurezza,
nevrosi, disarmonia.
Perché viviamo in un mondo complesso.
Perché è difficile orientarsi
in un mondo complesso.
E complesso non vuol dire complicato.
Intendo complesso
nel suo significato originario.
"Complesso" significa
"Intrecciato insieme".
È un concetto di molteplicità
e unità al tempo stesso.
È un mondo che è sia globale
sia locale, allo stesso tempo.
Un mondo che va veloce,
un mondo che è accelerato:
ogni cosa è un sistema.
Sembra quasi che il mondo si sia evoluto,
e sia entrato nell'era della complessità,
e la nostra mente ancora no,
che noi stessimo arrancando
dietro questo mondo.
E quindi?
Fino adesso, vi ho
buttato lì qualche pensiero,
un po’ di domande,
qualche banalità, un po’ di ansia.
Effettivamente, se ci mettiamo
a guardare questo mondo e a pensare,
c'è il rischio di rimanere paralizzati.
Io li capisco bene i giovani di oggi,
quelli che non hanno voglia
di alzarsi dal letto,
di uscire di casa.
Solo che io ho due figlie piccole.
Cosa racconto loro?
Avevo bisogno di un'ispirazione,
avevo bisogno di un'idea.
L'ho cercata, e forse l'ho trovata,
nel mondo dello sport.
Lo vivo tutti i giorni,
e racconta delle storie straordinarie.
E credo che lo sport
sia in grado di trasmettere
dei valori e delle emozioni
che sono uniche.
Vi siete mai chiesti
perché le grandi storie di sport
ci coinvolgono così tanto?
Perché ci appassionano così tanto?
Due cose: sono autentiche
e sono imprevedibili.
Provate a guardare un atleta
nel momento della sua gara,
nel momento della sua partita,
nel suo momento.
Osservate per un attimo il suo volto.
Guardate la tensione,
l’agone che ha in quel momento.
È autentico, è reale.
Lo sa che non ha un secondo ciak,
che non ha un replay.
E sa anche che il risultato
è imprevedibile,
perché ci sono statistiche,
ci sono analisi, ci sono sondaggi,
ci sono calcoli complessi;
ma alla fine, il risultato
è sempre incerto.
E non è forse questo
quello di cui stiamo parlando?
Non è così la nostra vita,
quando affrontiamo
la complessità del mondo?
È vita vera ed è imprevedibile.
Allora mi son detto:
“Guardiamo come fanno loro.
Come fanno i protagonisti
di queste storie straordinarie,
che guardo con tanta ammirazione,
ad affrontare l'inevitabile
imprevedibilità delle loro sfide?
La pressione dei media,
le aspettative dei fan,
l'attimo che li paralizza
prima di entrare in campo,
ce l’avranno anche loro.
Cosa fanno? Improvvisano, semplificano?
Lasciano che sia il caso,
a decidere la vittoria o meno?
Oppure hanno tutto sotto controllo?
E sanno esattamente
quale sarà il risultato?
Beh, nessuna delle due.
O meglio, entrambe.
Si preparano al meglio, si allenano
agendo su tutte le leve
su cui hanno il controllo:
l'alimentazione, la preparazione fisica,
il riposo, le analisi tecniche,
la tecnologia.
E poi danno il massimo,
senza risparmiarsi, senza lasciare niente.
A volte vincono, a volte perdono.
Per bravura degli avversari,
per un imprevisto, per un errore.
Ma possono essere frustrati,
possono essere stressati,
se sanno che si sono preparati al meglio
e poi hanno dato il massimo
nel momento della performance?
Ecco, secondo me
lo sport ci dà gli strumenti
per affrontare questa complessità.
O quantomeno, ci dà un'ispirazione.
Allenarsi tutti i giorni,
dando il meglio di noi,
e cercando di imparare
ogni giorno qualcosa di nuovo
con curiosità, senza pigrizia.
E poi, però, essere in grado di affrontare
ogni singolo evento della nostra vita,
ogni momento, con consapevole leggerezza.
Disciplinati, ma non severi
con noi stessi.
Responsabili, ma non in colpa.
Coraggiosi nell'affrontare una nuova sfida
nell'uscire dalla nostra zona di comfort,
senza essere bloccati
dalla paura di fallire.
Perché il fallimento non esiste.
Il fallimento è un tentativo
che non è andato a buon fine.
Esistono le sconfitte,
esistono le delusioni,
esistono le ferite anche profonde,
quelle che ti lasciano il segno.
Ma bisogna essere consapevoli
che queste ci servono soltanto
a migliorare, a crescere,
a essere più forti nel momento
in cui affronteremo la prossima sfida.
Ecco, quest'idea, questo approccio
mi è piaciuto fin da subito.
Mi ha tolto un pezzettino
di quel peso che avevo qui.
E sto cercando di applicarla
nella quotidianità, nel lavoro,
oggi su questo palco, con un successo -
più o meno, insomma, sto iniziando.
E poi ho provato a portarla in un progetto
che andasse al di là di me stesso,
che lasciasse il segno.
E insieme ad alcuni soci e amici,
abbiamo iniziato un'avventura
che abbiamo chiamato “Akto”,
che significa agisci -
play! - in esperanto.
E con “Akto” abbiamo due obiettivi:
quello di offrire
ai giovani dei paesi emergenti
una formazione professionale
di qualità e accessibile.
E poi di offrire loro dei posti di lavoro,
delle opportunità di lavoro concrete
nel mondo dello sport.
Siamo convinti che l'educazione
sia una delle sfide più importanti
per un futuro sostenibile
del nostro pianeta.
E crediamo nei valori dello sport,
e vogliamo fare la nostra piccola parte.
“Akto” è stata lanciata lo scorso anno
a ottobre a Capo Verde
e quest'anno arriverà
in Portogallo e in Brasile,
coinvolgendo migliaia di giovani,
offrendo centinaia
di possibilità di lavoro.
Ce la faremo?
Mi piacerebbe potervi dire
che ne sono sicuro,
ma il futuro è imprevedibile.
Intanto, ce la mettiamo tutta
e ce la giochiamo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)